et maintenant
de cela
kla voulu m
et jean-marie une seule patte et je suis
un con un petit bisou
clara morgane bonsoir faisait vingt ans
vous mesurez 1 m 65 vous posez 52 kg et
vous venez de remporter à cannes le hot
d'or de la meilleure starlette française
voilà voilà mesdames messieurs
alors vous avez déclaré je trouve
formidable que des actrices de x est
aujourd'hui la possibilité d'aller
donner leur avis dans les émissions de
télévision et dans les magazines mais
nous aussi que jean fou bon alors vous
avez fait un seul film et vous êtes déjà
une star non mon deuxième film est sorti
le 1er juin
ro donc il s'appelle la collectionneuse
et voilà c'est mon deuxième alors
pourquoi vous êtes devenu une star aussi
dit parce que vous n'êtes pas les les
sourcils trop maquillée pas les seins
refaits c'est ça je pense que on se
faisait une serre font se fait une
certaine image de la pornostar comme on
dit et moi j'ai gardé mon image et ça
étonne pas mal de pas mal de pas mal de
monde donc c'est peut-être une raison
correspondait à ce que les gens
attendent et peut-être non une femme
enfant peut-être une personne qu'on peut
croiser dans la rue qui peut être
n'importe qui pas forcément quelqu'un
destiné pour ça qu'à travailler pendant
des années jarry j'essaie d'être naturel
j'aime pas mon image et ça a l'air de
marcher j'ai mis mes lunettes
alors votre premier film c'était projet
x avec fred coppula le réalisateur fred
coppula le deuxième la collectionneuse
j'imagine c'est aussi avec fred coppula
toujours je vous ai signé pour trois
films avec lui bien plus c'est signé
pour trois films et on travaillera je
pense toujours ensemble parce qu'au delà
de du métier on est devenus de très
grands amis il est devenu une sorte de
grand frère pour moi
alors contrairement contrairement à
rafael anderson qui était assise à votre
place et quelques semaines qui vient de
publier hard chez grasset qui marche
très très bien d'ailleurs
vous n'êtes pas encore déçu par le
métier à vous oui parce qu'en fait j'ai
connu raphaël en 95 elle était un peu
comme vous ai trouvé ça formidable
maintenant là c'est à dire que j'ai fait
dans des conditions qui sont très
particulières voilà je suis consciente
de ce à quoi vous dites je fais du bien
à la pornographie qu'armand plaisir se
voit dans mes yeux
ouais j'espère en tout cas faire du bien
à pornographie au début c'était pas mon
objectif je suis arrivé comme ça pour
m'amuser et plus plus ça va plus je me
sens bien dans ma position et j'ai envie
de lui faire du bien en même temps le
monde du golf à un but comme certains
hommes alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que clara a une particularité elle ne
tourne qu'avec un seul partenaire
masculin c'est 100 mecs ces grecs
santoro vous tourner qu'avec lui ben
disons que à la base j'avais comme
objectif de tourner avec des personnes
dont j'avais envie donc forcément je
tourne avec mon ami et je dis pas que je
tournerai jamais avec personne d'autre
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que tu tomberas avec des personnes dans
géant oui parce que c'est nécessaire
pour moi lui tourne avec d'autres filles
oui vous dites je sais que dans sa tête
quand il est avec les autres c'est
vraiment un travail oit sur la leyre
ignorons c'est à dire que je sais qu'à
par fun qu'il aime c'est moi je sais que
si la direction s'est pas non plus par
hasard mais comme peur j'entendais la
question que vous avez posé je pense
qu'il ya contre le sexe sans amour
existe mais ça c'est autre chose
faire un film c'est pas c'est pas comme
si on faisait l'amour pour de vrai
sans arrêt des coupures je veux dire
c'est faut être sur un tournage pour
comprendre ce qu'est un tournage quand
même c'est pas cette pole est pour les
hommes d'ailleurs puisque fo commune qui
garde la gaule tout le temps il indique
tout sûr que dia une coupure toi tu
attends ça met à 6h30 c'est ici exposé
parce que pour parler peut pas les
performances 1 j'ai un copain mais
connaît plein de gens dans le cinéma et
qui ont qui s'il leur est arrivé de
tourner dans des films de travailler
dans des films comme ça
x et il disait que les comédiens
s'astiquer le menhir tout le temps et
qu'ils arrivaient à garder la gaule
pendant des heures et des heures sinon
toute la journée c'est une sacré
performance avec le coup de chapeau
c'est l'oeil de moi je trouve qu'ils
sont trop moi j'aimerais bien de temps
en temps qui met un mec normal dans la
bande
qu'est ce que parce qu'elle apprenne aux
femmes un nouvel disent ah bah oui mais
sur la casse et que c'était plus gros
ces blocs forcément cdc des bestiaux
d'élevage quand même parce que moi
j'aimerais bien moi à la maison je la
prends moi quand je la prends comme ça
j'en vois encore un bon guide et bassin
mais moi et si je mets deux mains moi je
vois plus rien mais il ya un terrain qui
dépasse c'est normal ça n'était point
d'eau
bien bien bien là ça c'est fait alors
lorsqu'on avait deux donc avec santoro
et tourne avec d'autres filles vous vous
pensez donc effectivement quand et avec
elle c'était que du travail et vous l'a
dit toute façon et si vous vous proposer
de tourner avec une énorme star du porno
comme rocco par exemple c'est pas ce
genre de propositions qui
m'intéresserait c'est de toute façon
c'est moi qui ferai la démarche dans
parlement réalisateur dans la mesure où
un acteur me plairait j'aurais envie de
tourner avec lui c'est assez difficile à
croire mais c'est la réalité une
question de quoi de grain de peau dorée
et d'attirance comme on a dans la vie on
est à des personnes qui sont différentes
des autres
oui les chèques avec d'échangé pour
votre amie clara c'est évidemment plus
facile pour lui nadir gérer je suis au
travail s'il te plaît ne ne m'appelle
pas je nettoierai que je suis au bureau
et c'est vrai qu'il n'a aucune raison
non mais sérieusement il a aucune raison
de ne pas être amoureux doués ou vous de
vous quitter puisque de la mesure vous
tout tout tout va bien c'est à dire le
charcutier du coin lui si jamais il a
embrassé la boulangère en cachette
derrière l'église
s'il se fait gauler c'est l'horreur et
la 10e qu'est ce tu fais chérubins je
bosse
je rendrai vers 7 heures départ en
retard parce qu on a encore de la bonne
pioche le grade
c'est exactement ça oui alors vos
parents vos parents et vos parents vous
dites avec mes parents j'ai préféré
jouer franc jeu
c'est mieux qui semble agacer dessus ou
chanter en même temps alors quelques
mois auparavant vous aviez déjà à vous
et à votre mère votre bisexualité oui
elle avait toutefois la première fois
ben c'était pas trop longtemps en vain
mais elle m'avait parlé de quelque chose
et moi je l'avais dit bon il faut que je
te parle de moi parce que vont il ya des
choses que tu sais pas et c'est vrai que
j'ai une assurance qui vers les femmes
elle m'a dit qu'elle s'en doutait un peu
parce que c'est vrai que depuis que je
suis jeune j'ai beaucoup de copines mais
elles sont toutes jolies on sait pas
pourquoi
donc voila mais je suis à vous et
sincèrement et c'est vrai que quand on a
eu cette proposition pour monter sur
paris et tout ce à quoi je dédie aussi
directement ainsi qu'à mon père c'est
vrai qu'ils n'ont pas très bien pris
c'est normal ils ont préféré que ce soit
à vos quatre quelque chose comme ça mais
bon au fur et à mesure du temps le
barreau est pas loin
depuis 2006
alors est ce que greg était avec vous
quand vous êtes allé voir vos pas on est
descendus ensemble on leur a dit ils ont
pas compris normal mais on leur a
expliqué à montrer et après ils ont
compris alors attendez si vos parents
vous aviez dit ce jour-là écoute carats
ont le plus de voir je n'aurais jamais
fait vous auriez arrêter le porno c'est
bien mais mes parents même trop pour ça
et ce qu'ils veulent c'est que
chaleureuse ouais je pose la question
mais part entière oui mais profitez-en
qui va il sait que je suis bi choix bien
quoi c'est tout et aujourd'hui vous
parler encore et votre mère au téléphone
vous appelé deux fois par an une fois
tous les deux jours
rien n'est obligé de garder ce contact
elles sont à votre voix vous êtes
heureuse que tout va bien
oui elle est montée sur paris je suis
descendu très peu de temps sur marseille
mais dans l'entourage vos parents il ya
des gens qui leur disent ils dans ta
fille laura c'est l'enfer parce que je
fais quelques chez pas mal de télé quand
même ce mois ci je fais cinq couvertures
de magazines je suis quand même assez
médiatisé pour une fille du x et c'est
vrai que c'est un énorme poids pour eux
quand même
moi j'aime peu l'impression de m'être
défilé en venant sur paris et de leur
avoir un petit peu imposé sa s c'est ça
qui me gêne c'est le regard des autres
dans une enfance heureuse à une
adolescence plutôt libre non mes parents
ça c'est un petit peu froissé à mon
adolescence parce que moi j'avais besoin
de liberté de sortir avec mes copines le
soir tout ça et ça ça a été très
difficile
je suis pas sorti tout seul il a fallu
que je rencontre greg personnel vous
aviez saison et que mes parents vas y
qu'on soit bien semble qu'ils aient
confiance en lui pour me laisser sortir
et tout ça alors vous vous prépariez un
bts action commerciale 8 et
fonctionnaires grecs
donc quoi après ce poste c'est le
facteur et voilà
que comme d'habitude sonne toujours deux
fois s'est pas rencontrés dans ce genre
de serre et alors vous aviez faire du
naturisme au cap d'agde ça c'était deux
ans après entre autres c'est moi qui
avais envie d'essayer parce que moi je
connais ça qu'à travers les bouquins de
films de ravalec de houellebecq etc
mais non vraiment je parle du cap d'agde
de kara jeu par big apple
j'étais une parade avec j'aimerais y
aller c'est très sympa c'est très sympa
et jean centre est simple dvd envoyé dès
cet été
on sait que nirvana oui j'ai beaucoup
d'amis là bas on pensait alors qu'est ce
qui se passe au cap d'ail parce que les
gens savent pas tous
alors il ya rien camping il ya des
hôtels pour ceux qui veulent pas vivre
tout nu tout le temps et c'est vrai que
le soir il ya des boîtes un petit peu
particulière échangiste comme on dit et
on y va ou pas oui mais dans la journée
présentes sur la plage supermarché ça
baise non non pas du tout non non il ya
un mélange de québec de de pureté de
gens avec le naturisme et toute cette
culture et d'autres qui sera pour les
fans sont prêts mentalement tu es mon
idée du marché de prendre un blonde aux
yeux des couilles de
de prendre un autre melon avec sam ont
fait effet un côté nature et que
maintenant que je pense en plus que
c'est le rêve de c'est un peu le rêve de
tout le monde de passer communiste et
bien sûr de sa bande à part c'est un
petit peu ça me fait penser à l'époque
des orgies romaines tout le monde fait
qu'ils voulaient mais jamais personne
n'est forcé on fait ce qu'on veut quand
on en a envie
c'est génial moi c'est la partie qui me
plaît c'est qu'on peut ne pas le seul
oui dit non non ça ce serait vraiment ça
ce serait le contraire de la liberté
commence alors pour vos vingt ans oui
grec vous invite à paris tous pour
retrouver des amis du cap d'agde
ouais et alors là vous arrivez au salon
autre vidéo pour voir les copains quoi
on est montés pour aller au salon de
vidéos parce qu'en s'intéressaient de
près ou de loin à ce milieu et on
voulait aussi voir paris une espèce de
vocations comme déjà chez vous
pas forcément je pense la vocation
c'était au niveau de l'esprit libre et
une certaine ouverture d'esprit je pense
qu'ils étaient là et c'est ce jour là où
on a rencontré fred coppula dans ses
valises à terre qui est des boules c'est
qu'elle en a regardé paris cinq minutes
c'est exactement ça on n'aime pas du
tout paris alors quand on vous parle du
sexe vous dites vous demande ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe vous dites je
préfère rien j'aime tout petit pas
vraiment vrai si c'est vrai à oui à des
trucs qui me pèse pas dans le budget pas
détail y'a n'ont pas de détails pas
forcément il ya une chaude en
particulier qui ne me plaît pas vraiment
voilà
mais à part ça j'aime j'aime pas une
chose en particulier parce que ce serait
se limiter j'aime un ensemble de choses
au niveau de la sexualité le bien les
différentes ambiances et revisite
certains jours j'aime bien t'attraper
par surprise puisque toujours attaché
c'est greg lit et les bandes et les yeux
non j'aime bien les deux côtés oui
j'aime bien jouer
oui vous aimez fred coppula j'ai
beaucoup suivi sa carrière
mais j'ai cru que tu trouves que
mademoiselle a quand même un plan de
carrière si ça rigole pas c'est quand
même ce dernier vous hier maria là bas
mais non c'est bien là vous savez qu'on
ne bouge pas on ne bouge pas pendant les
ting
[Applaudissements]
non
on ne bouge pas on en est génial bien ça
c'est fait
interview première fois premier souvenir
ma première fois à tout de suite
bah oui c'est un truc dont on parle de
sexe au gip en heure mais ça aurait pu
être sympa moi je trouve et avant 13 ans
vous avez commencé tard en plus 15 ans
et demi celle du premier choc de votre
vie comme il ya tellement du sexe en
annonces y'a pas longtemps ce qu'avec un
membre de ma famille
j'ai vu
venus est valable je vais me gêner
premier mensonge il n'a pas duré
longtemps c'est une tromperie le trompe
et vague
oui bon c'est ça durait deux jours que
j'ai je le jure on est déçus il a fait
avant moi
c'est scandaleux la destruction du
premier péché la gourmandise sucré
première main mon papa ouais premier
coup de foudre
greg greg ce grec quand même premier
baiser sans la langue sans la loi sans
la langue c'était tard ah bon j'ai
commencé avec la langue
j'avais déjà mon mac comme à côté attend
des jeux c'était en quatrième q vous
aviez pas quel âge
sa maison est alors maintenant il
dribble et avec la danse avec la langue
avec la langue si tu ne t'es pas un an
plus tard pour la première fois la danse
avec greg
oui à l'âge de 16 ans oui je dis oui
comme ça parce qu'il ya eu un effet avec
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'était un très
mauvais souvenir
ah bon c'est pas bien passé là ma
première vraie foi voilà des premières
fois avec une fille c'était pour une
femme c'était pour l'anniversaire de
greg je comprends pas tous heureusement
plus souvent leur a préparé un petit
cadeau
exactement c'est une fille dont j'avais
envie et finalement ça c'est pas prévu
on était dans une soirée tout ça et on
est rentrés tous les trois voilà qui
s'en va pas durer gré il ya un bravo et
bien félicitations situation est bénie
des dieux vous rentrez jamais avec un
copain vaincu pourra voir mes copains
oui il pourrait avoir envie de rentrer
quatre copains greg aussi faudrait que
ce soit moi qui en ai envie ah bon c'est
vous qui décidez oui mais je pense que
c'est normal dans un couple
que ce soit la fin la femme a plus
besoin de choses pour le sexe comme un
homme c'est assez facile elle est pas
mal c'est bien enfin souvent une fille a
plus besoin d'eux des choses pour la
première fois trois vous venez de le
dire première fois 4 enfin tout dire
c'était y'a pas longtemps et a5 jamais
ah non vous êtes tout à apprendre encore
première scène de ménage quand même
j'espère passer à l'entente a eu
beaucoup depuis
oui on discute beaucoup hein on aime
bien vous aimez bien pour la
réconciliation merci bien sûr les
premiers annoncé qu'ils voteraient
premier amant sur pareil non chez elle
c'est fred coppula
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu